les négociations sur la taxation des
gars fassent sont au point mort mercredi
les états unis ont annoncé leur souhait
de faire une pause dans les discussions
sur la taxation des multinationales qui
ont débuté en janvier dernier
une décision que regrette le commissaire
européen aux affaires économiques
paolo gentiloni je regrette profondément
la décision américaine de mettre un
frein aux discussions internationales
sur la taxation des entreprises du
numérique
j'espère qu'il s'agira d'un revers
temporaire plutôt que d'un arrêt
définitif
depuis le 1er janvier 2019
la france a décidé de taxer les géants
du numérique tels que google amazon ou
encore facebook à hauteur de 3 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires
l'objectif des négociations en cours la
mise en place d'une taxation du digital
plus juste le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'est insurgée en
dénonçant une provocation de la part des
états unis
c'est une provocation aux vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des partenaires de l'oscd on
était à à quelques centimètres d'un
accord sur la taxation des géants du
numérique au moment où les gens du
numérique sont peut-être les seuls au
monde à avoir tiré d'immenses bénéfices
de la crise du coronavirus look c'est
une provocation vis-à-vis non seulement
de tout ce qu'elle ocde négocier de
bonne foi mais vis-à-vis de tous les
citoyens de la planète qui se disent les
quand même légitime que les gens du
numérique payent leurs impôts en plus
des états unis et de la france
135 pays se sont engagés dans ces
négociations pour aboutir d'ici la fin
de l'année 2020 un accord sur la
taxation des multinationales un objectif
qui semble compromis avec le retrait des
états unis en cas de non accord bruno le
maire annonce que la france appliquera
sa taxe nationale
suspendu durant les négociations